rapporteur de la commission du
développement durable et de
l'aménagement du territoire pour 10
minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le Président de la Commission
mes chers collègues je rêve d'un peuple
qui commencerait par brûler les clôtures
et laisser croître croître les forêts
je laissais je rêve un peuple qui
commencerait par brûler les clôtures et
laisser croître les forêts
c'est une magnifique citation du
philosophe naturaliste et poète
américain Henri David taureau que je
souhaite partager avec vous il y a écrit
son amour pour la nature une nature
libre sans grillage ou les animaux
sauvages se promènent à leur guise sans
entrave libre une circulation qui se
trouve en harmonie en harmonie avec la
nature cette citation est également en
harmonie avec cette proposition de loi
visant à limiter l'en grillagement des
espaces naturels et à protéger la
propriété privée présentée aujourd'hui
dans l'hémicycle au sein de la niche
modem je remercie l'ensemble des députés
démocrates et indépendants pour leur
soutien sans faille il est à noter que
c'est un texte qui a été voté à
l'unanimité en commission du
développement durable le 28 septembre
dernier
je remercie chaleureusement le président
Jean-Marc zoulesi pour l'excellente
conduite de nos travaux
je veux saluer ici le sénateur LR
Jean-Noël Cardou auteur de la
proposition de loi initiale qui a été
aussi votée à l'unanimité au Sénat
d'avoir écrit un premier texte courageux
courageux lui le chasseur pour lutter
contre ce phénomène qui s'étend en
France d'année en année et pour la
biodiversité
remercions également Bastien Lachaud et
François Cormier bouligeon qui avait
déposé des textes à l'Assemblée
nationale ainsi que l'ensemble des
députés de tous les groupes politiques
qui ont participé à l'écriture du texte
en commission notamment madame lesables
Lisa belluco monsieur Stéphane de
Lautrec madame Manon Meunier et Madame
Mathilde Paris ainsi que Nicolas sangsue
cette liste n'est évidemment pas
exhaustive le phénomène de
langrillagement n'est pas nouveau il est
présent depuis des décennies en France
et notamment en Sologne ou des
propriétaires terriens ont engagé et en
grillage encore leur domaine avec des
clôtures enterrées dans le sol et dont
la hauteur peut atteindre 2 mètres
depuis le 19e siècle la loi évidemment
autorise un propriétaire à clore son
domaine nombre d'entre eux ont donc en
grillagé le leur pour se protéger des
intrusions mais certains y participent
et ils pratiquent du ball-trap vivant ou
les animaux sont tués sans aucune chance
de s'échapper cette pratique n'est pas
de la chasse c'est une tuerie organisée
par des enfants gâtés irresponsables
si la Sologne et le territoire le plus
touché par l'angriègement elle est loin
d'être la seule concernée en effet
l'élan de la somme la Bourgogne le sud
de l'Île-de-France ont également des
territoires au sein desquels les
clôtures sont nombreuses les animaux
sauvages la nature sont les grandes
victimes de l'engriègement en empêchant
le libre passage des animaux sauvages
langrillagement contribue à la rupture
des continuités écologiques les animaux
ne peuvent pas passer les clôtures
certains s'isèrent et ventre s'y
prennent les pattes ils meurent d'agonie
et faites aussi les photos pardon
circule sur internet en montrant ces
animaux pris au piège ses photons sont
insoutenables mes chers collègues nous
avons aujourd'hui raison d'agir
de plus en période d'incendie les
grillages représentent et présentent un
réel danger pour la sécurité publique où
les secours ne peuvent intervenir les
animaux eux se trouvent piégés dans les
flammes ils ne peuvent fuir le feu nous
l'avons constaté cet été dans les
dramatiques incendies notamment dans les
Landes par ailleurs les clôtures ont un
impact paysager néfaste pour le
développement du tourisme rural et
l'esthétisme le forêt cela est
indéniable nous pourrions aussi évoquer
le frein à l'exercice de la police de
l'environnement
c'est pas ce qui ne peuvent rentrer dans
ces propriétés clauses ce fléau de
l'engriègement doit trouver une faim
espérer par le plus grand nombre d'entre
nous dans son domicile évidemment
aujourd'hui mais aussi avec nos
concitoyens mes chers collègues il
s'agit de préserver la nature cette
nature elle est si fragile les animaux
sauvages les arbres les différentes
espèces végétales les mers les océans
toute cette biodiversité souffre depuis
notre trop nombreuses années à cause de
l'homme de ses actions trop souvent
dommageables à cette belle nature il
nous faut la préserver préserver notre
nature il nous faut la charrie la chérie
un écrivain qui vivait dans ma
cercotique dans ma circonscription le
grand écrivain célébré au Panthéon
Maurice Genevoix était si amoureux il
savait magistralement d'écrire ces
mystères et ses couleurs passionnés par
son territoire la loi la Sologne merci à
toi Maurice Genevoix devant la
représentation nationale je rends
hommage à cet écrivain qui par sa plume
sublimer la nature et qui a placé
au-dessus de tout la liberté cette
liberté qui lui avait tant manqué durant
la première guerre ses écrits m'ont
toujours ému quand j'étais enfant je
pense à ceux sur la forêt les étangs de
Sologne la nature les bruyères et les
animaux sauvages c'est faisant et ses
cailles je vous invite donc à lire les
routes de l'aventure comme je l'ai fait
moi-même enfant j'admire la nature et
tout ce qu'elle offre je suis souvent
interpellé par les habitants pour m'en
parler sur sa détérioration comme vous
je le suppose dans vos territoires
nous sommes ici évidemment les députés
protecteurs de l'humain mais aussi de
l'humain dans sa nature
l'engriègement participe à cette
dégradation je suis évidemment contacté
par les associations qui luttent depuis
des nombreuses années et qui vise à
limiter ce phénomène nous les avons en
commission auditionner rencontrer
travailler avec eux ils nous ont fait
part de leur désarroi de leur combat
depuis des dizaines d'années pas cette
situation qui est devenue incontrôlable
je remercie la famille Louis de l'avoir
fait depuis des années Jean-François
Bernardin Dominique Noguet mais aussi
évidemment Sébastien Camus président de
l'association chasseur promenèrent et
faut me dire en Sologne de sa présence
aujourd'hui et son indéfectible soutien
dans ce combat et de ce préjudice et de
ses merveilleux conseils ce texte ici
présenté dans cette hémicycle et le
fruit d'un long travail en commission
grâce au travail de l'ensemble des
groupes politiques ils ont été
j'aurais nous avons amélioré le texte
c'est ça l'honneur du travail
parlementaire lors de nos échanges le 28
septembre j'ai souhaité que le
désengriagement s'opère sur l'ensemble
des espaces naturels et ce le 6 octobre
je souhaite sécuriser au maximum ce
dispositif ainsi dans cette émission
j'accepterai un amendement qui mentionne
les zones naturelles et forestières
lorsque leur état estoire est couvert
par un plan local d'urbanisme et les
espaces naturels pour les territoires
non couverts par un document d'urbanisme
ainsi je garantirai en acceptant ses
amendements que ce texte s'applique dans
tous les milieux naturels sans ambiguïté
la commission également trouvée à
consensus quand nos dimensions des
éventuels nouvelles clôtures je le
répète ici il ne s'agit absolument pas
d'un texte sur la chasse mais sur la
libre circulation des animaux sauvages
que les débats et le compromis trouvé en
commission puis ce jour devant la
représentation nationale aboutit
rapidement pour que les territoires
soient désengrâgés et que nos paysages
retrouvent leur beauté mes chers
collègues 90 amendements ont été déposés
pour ce texte nos débats vont à nouveau
être riches et passionnés sur ce sujet
de désengriagement et la liberté des
animaux sauvages je m'en réjouis
personnellement et espère que nous
discutions se reconstructives et
respectueuse de chacun je suis sûr qu'à
l'ici de cette examen et de mesures
adopter ce texte sera par vous sur tous
les bancs perfectionnés les habitants
vivant dans ces territoires en grillagés
attendent depuis des décennies une
limitation des clôtures l'adoption de ce
texte en commission était historique je
vous invite donc à poursuivre ce débat
je le dis également pour le groupe
démocrate après marque fenault le
président Mignola est aujourd'hui le
président Mattei le MoDem a toujours
respecté les oppositions nous sommes les
garants de cette respect des oppositions
dans cette articles comme tout le monde
et nous y ferons attention c'est donc
avec l'esprit du MoDem avec l'esprit du
présent Mattéi Mignola et phéno que je
respecterai l'ensemble des propositions
est venu des oppositions merci à vous
merci chers collègues nous entamons
maintenant la
[Musique]